ليس هذا صدر دجاج حقيقي انه دجاج مصنع في
مختبر باستخدام خلايا حيوانيه ستجد هذه
اللحوم الصناعيه طريقها قريبا الى موائد
الامريكيين بعد ان وافقت عليها اداره
الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه في خطوه كبيره
نحو حقبه جديده في انتاج اللحوم
لحم دجاج
في خلايا جذعيه من لحوم الماشيه او
الدواجن حيه وتزرع الخلايا في مفعلات
حيويه وتعالج بعناصر غذائيه فتتحول الى
خلايا عضليه ناضجه لتصبح فيما بعد لحم
المستظرعا يشبه قطع اللحم الحقيقيه في
شكله ومذاقه
كما قلت ليس بديلا للحوم انه لحم ينمو من
خلايا حيوانيه حقيقيه لذا ما نقوم به هو
اخذ خلايا حيوانيه عاليه الجوده ونبحث عن
الخلايا التي يمكنها الاستمرار في النمو
خارج الجسم الحيوان بطريقه قويه جدا وصحيه
بعد ان وافقت سنغافوره على اعتماد اللحوم
المصنعه مخبريا طعاما امنا للاستهلاك
البشريه
والعقاقير في الولايات المتحده الضوء
الاخضر لشركه ابسيد فودز التي تتخذ من
كاليفورنيا مقر لها لانتاج اللحوم المصنعه
وتامل الشركه ان تتاح للمستهلكين
الامريكيين قريبا فرصه تناول اللحوم
اللذيذه منتجه مباشره من الخلايا
الحيوانيه بدل قتل الحيوانات او ذبحها
عده شركات ناشئه لانتاج وتسويق هذا النوع
من اللحوم وتقول ان ذلك سيتيح للبشر
استهلاك البروتين الحيواني بطرق لا تلحق
ضررا بالبيئه بدلا من الاسلوب التقليدي
للتربيه الحيوانيه ذي الاثار البيئيه
المدمره كما تؤكد ان لهذه اللحوم مزايا
صحيه لانها معقمه وامنه من التلوث
مقارنه بالبروتينات الحيوانيه الطبيعيه
تحتوي ايضا على كميه اقل من الدهون
المشبعه لكن للوصول الى وجهتها النهائيه
رفوف في السوبر ماركت لا تزال صناعه
اللحوم بالمزروعه تواجه عقبات كبيره فهي
مضطره الى جذب مزيد من التمويل لزياده
الانتاج واجعله في متناول الجميع